[Music]
let's go to emma in provo utah what's up
emma
hi
oh nothing much just tired
welcome to 21st century what's up
so my brother has had a couple of felony
charges against him
and i want to know how to help my
pregnant sister-in-law um be a sport for
her
um she thinks it's some sort of scheme
against him
and
i know that i probably can't change her
mind but i want to be there for her
but i don't want to like hurt to think
that i
believe that my brother is totally
innocent
okay so what did what what did your
brother do
well um he has a couple of charges that
have to do with a minor
he had to one charge that um he was
pretending to be a minor and then that
he had some inappropriate conversations
with a minor online okay did he ever
connect with him in person
no okay that you know of right yeah yeah
that i know of no okay um
and you're you think he did this
i think yeah i think he could have done
it um it was really surprising for me
and like i would have never guessed it
but there's other things that in their
relationship and other things that i've
heard from my siblings that make me
believe that he could have done this
so have you sat down with that and just
sat in it for a second that's hard
it is
i've tried to my my husband's like honey
you need to like
work through this yeah and then
just not try to get in his head because
i do that i try to get in people's heads
don't do that it's an absolutely waste
it's an absolute waste of your time and
it ends up poisoning your body literally
with the cortisol and adrenaline like
you it's it don't do it
um your homework tonight before we even
get started and i'll answer your other
question here i want you to write your
brother a letter that you're never going
to send him
okay
and i want you to be honest with him
about how pissed off you are
how angry you are that he screwed up the
whole family that he blew up his own
little marriage
did he hurt another child multiple other
children right i want you to be honest
in this letter okay
okay don't cut corners don't be like oh
what if you're not going to send it to
him this letter is for you
okay
okay
and
if possible i'd love for you to read it
out loud to your husband
you've heard me say this before it's
from the great david kessler grief
demands a witness
somebody has to sit with you
as much as that sucks and your brother
has blown up everything
yeah right
yeah and when people blow up everything
a couple of things happen either some
people rally around them and go it can't
be because i can't live in the world
that i've i'm now being asked to inhabit
which sounds like what your
sister-in-law is doing
yeah right or people
they are able to see oh no
or they deflect or they ignore kind of
like you've done like ah it's just i'm
just gonna ignore it and i'm just gonna
move on
everybody's just gotta sit in reality
right so we're not going to get on to
sister
right now she is duct taping and
stringing and ribboning her life
together at the moment
yeah right it's exploded
yeah
and
um she's she is in the situation that
i've been with when somebody's house
burns completely down and they're
heading home
and they say
they're told hey your house is in as a
total loss and you talk to them and they
say
well i'm just going to go by and see
what um what what's what what's what i
can grab what mem you know things are
left
and you say
hey it's all gone and they say yeah i
know but i'm like there's gonna be some
stuff that like they can't they can't
see that picture until they're in it
right that's where she's at yeah i don't
beat up people like that i don't go to
war with people like that their world is
a mess right
here's the hardest thing
has she asked for your help
no
and that
ah it's the worst
because you
your brother's a part of you and you
want to help make this thing right right
now you want to get in and start
sweeping up and cleaning up and
repainting so that everything can be as
it was
and everything will never be as it was
even if he's found not guilty coming
home as you mentioned there's some stuff
that needs to be discussed right
yeah and even if he's found guilty and
he gets 10 years because he didn't make
actual contact or he gets five years and
includes it down to two and he's on
probation whatever
everything's different now
yeah do you have your own kids
i do i have two boys
yeah and now you've already backed it up
and said
when did i leave him did he ever have
right you've already been down that road
yeah right and every future engagement
every future family thing all that is is
screwed up now because of one person's
decisions and so you want to go fix it
and hear me say this and it breaks my
heart to say it out loud
you can't
it just is
and so the greatest gift you can give
your sister-in-law is to go see her in
person are you all close will she see
you
um i
don't know if she'll see me but she's
like an hour and a half away okay
um she's kind of mad at us
yeah that's fine that's fine um
taylor you love her and tell her
you are here to walk alongside her any
way that you can
and that you're here and you and your
husband decide what does that mean
financially does that mean when they get
kicked out of the house because there's
no more income coming in or if it's
child care or if she has to move closer
to you guys so that y'all can help keep
the baby while she's right whatever that
looks like
um y'all you and your husband decide
what your boundaries are going to be and
then you let her know i'm here at any
time
and check in on her once a week but
don't insert yourself into her life if
she doesn't want you there because
that's not going to be supportive and
help that's about you trying to make
this thing a little less sucky for you
and it actually doesn't help her
yeah okay
maybe it's door dash we're gonna send
you food once a week you don't have to
eat it but we just love you and we're
gonna send you food once a week for the
next foreseeable future that might be a
thing y'all can do you know what i mean
and you can get with your other brothers
and sisters and say hey i'll
all do the food train we're gonna make
sure they got a meal once a week
here's what you're doing you're playing
a long game now you're playing a 10-year
game a 15-year game i want there to be a
trail of
text messages and personal letters and
visits if possible and meals sent
we kept trying to show up for you and
for that little one we kept trying to
show up we kept trying to show up we
kept trying to show up
okay that's the game we're playing and
listen you have to grieve this i'm so
sorry
thanks
i know i've been avoiding it i know i
know it's and you have to i get it i get
it i get it i get it and it doesn't have
to be yeah it kind of needs to be soon
let it be soon okay
okay and when it washes over you it's
gonna be brutal
that's why you gotta do with other
people do you have a girlfriend or two
you can call that will come sit with you
yeah i do i do
maybe maybe give that a shot man i
maybe your husband's not the right guy
to read that letter to you somebody's to
sit down and listen to you
and hold you and hug you and
so
child abuse is so destructive to so many
people into those sweet sweet kids
who some reason had access to online
engagements